the man accused of shooting and killing
a tow truck employee faced a judge today
thank you for joining us at 4 I'm
Kirsten Joyce and I'm Brian Loftus now
police say this man 27 year old Jaden
herder ran from the scene after pulling
the trigger and was caught hours later
happened yesterday just before 11
o'clock in the morning near the arts
district at the intersection of Commerce
and Wyoming Victoria Saha is live now
with how they track down that individual
Victoria
yeah when I first got here today an
employee for all in Towing confirmed
that it was their business that had the
shooting and that one of their employees
had died today the business was closed
but there were flowers and candles left
on their doorstep
a business that's usually bustling now
quiet as employees of all in Towing
mourn their colic jonette Dominguez
every morning I came in he was outside
and I just waved to him and said good
morning I mean I've been over to his
place also for notary work and
I'm still in shock a woman who works
across the street and didn't want to be
identified says she could see from her
window the chaos unfolding Tuesday
Morning an arrest report obtained by 8
news now reveals on Tuesday 27 year old
Jay and herder walked into the business
to pick up his rented Tesla that was
towed but there was some paperwork that
wasn't notarized this is when an
employee went to get Dominguez the
employee tells police Dominguez wouldn't
give her the car without the proper
paperwork this upset herder the report
goes on to say that is when he pulled
out his gun and shot Dominguez then ran
off it just happened so fast but the
next thing we knew all the ambulance and
all the police cars were here Dominguez
died at the hospital but as police began
to piece this together they got a call
from an attorney in Henderson saying
herder was in his office and wanted to
turn himself in he made his first court
appearance on Wednesday
setting please
I tried speaking to the employees inside
but obviously they were very distraught
I'm told that Dominguez was also a
partner in this company but there's no
word on when this business will be open
back again reporting in downtown
Victoria Saha 8 News Now